hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
just checking in to see how your week's
going we're coming out of it man
i can feel it restaurants are starting
to open up
people are sitting together breathing at
each other but maybe they got vaccine
vaccine vaccinated maybe they got
vaccinated
i have no idea i just know that i'm up
soon
i'm up soon and it's like what are you
gonna go with the vaccine you're going
with coke or pepsi
you're gonna go johnson and johnson or
uh [ __ ] uh
freddie got fingered whatever the [ __ ]
the yellow one's called
let's look up now let's just let's just
to add to the uh
uh misinformation out here let's have a
a non [ __ ]
almost said chemist non-vaccine person
johnson johnson and johnson
do you know that they're they're that
company was sold a long time ago but the
kids that are all relatives of the first
johnson and johnson
they still get [ __ ] money and they
sit around like [ __ ]
just raking it in you yeah every time
you got a bunion
they make up they make enough money to
buy another canvas to put on their easel
and pretend they know how to paint
you know some giant mansion out on long
island i forget it's a long story all
right johnson
and johnson vaxxy
versus the pfizer onset pfizer
yeah want you will take tits and you
will be on ice with the fiora
all right pfizer versus johnson and
johnson
same-sex couple versus
the fuhrer let's see
okay comparing three covid19 this is the
first one that comes up
and it's on statnews.com
and it's in the health comparing the
kovid 19 vaccines developed by
what's pfizer moderna monderna
and johnson johnson [ __ ] deal with it
we're here
we're queer we're staying together um in
an ideal world a pandemic vaccine could
be delivered
in a single shot so supplies could be
stretched
to cover a lot of people well yeah that
would be ideal
you'd only have to take it once it would
trigger no side effect more significant
than a sore arm it would be easy to ship
and store
soon it seems this ideal of the coven 19
vaccine will be in
will be within reach last friday johnson
and johnson we support you
announce that a one-dose vaccine being
developed by its vaccine division
johnson
had been this is just making me tell me
these names man
let's take me back to world war ii and
what they tried to do there had been
shown to be 66 protective
against moderate to severe covet
infection
in a multi-cultural multi-country study
but importantly it was 85 percent
effective in preventing against
severe disease and there was no
hospitalizations or death among the
people
in the va vaccine arm of a large
clinical trial overall
fsc varied a bit geographically
you know what i'm not reading this
that's too much brain power for this
time in the morning hey let's talk about
the celtics
i'm gonna get mine in in march is what
i'm gonna do and i'm just gonna wait
you know see if anybody from february
and january had any weird side effects
i'm just that's what i'm going to do i'm
doing it for you young people i'm going
to use myself as a guinea pig i might as
well right
i still smoke the occasional cigar i did
plenty of damage to my liver
i love all these people i'm not taking
the [ __ ] vaccine and they're sitting
eating [ __ ] ho-hos and tv dinners
like they're not already poisoning
themselves yeah but here's the
difference
i decide i decide what toxins i put in
my body
this is my temple
and if i want to spray graffiti all over
the inside that's going to be my choice
um all right
people it's black history month
so as a white person i think i need to
confess about something
this is how white i am last night i was
watching the celtics of course right
there a really white thing to do
um and they're playing the atlanta hawks
right so i'm sitting there and i'm
watching the game i turned it on like
the third quarter
i got a little busy and uh we were
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of us we
were down by like 20.
battled to the end as all celtic teams
do
and uh i'm watching it and at one point
somebody on our team f fouled one of the
hawks
right and the hawks go to the line first
of all i put the [ __ ] game on and
it's
the nba now it's like you know the
celtics are green and white they're
wearing like gray and green
and the atlanta hawks are like red white
and yellow and they're wearing like all
black
and then somebody's got like lime green
sneakers on it's just like the colors
are just out the [ __ ] window i just
think now they're just like listen
we got the graphics so you know who the
[ __ ] playing and then we're just going
to create 97 jerseys
so you know some so all of our jerseys
will match
all the different colors of all the
jordan ones
that's that's my thing but i'm an old
guy so i i still go by colors
my eyesight is bad i can't [ __ ] read
you know at a distance or even up close
i mean i'm there
i'm i'm a [ __ ] mess so i'm sitting
there i'm watching the game
so one of the celtics follows one fouls
one of the hawks
so the hawk guy goes to line and they do
a close-up of him like a three-quarter
shot not to get all hollywood but that's
what it was basically you know
from about mid-chest up and i see on
his jersey it said mlk
and in my white brain i was going like
wait they played milwaukee
i thought they were playing atlanta
and then i looked and i saw on the thing
it's like celtics first atlanta i was
like
i was like oh [ __ ] black history month
martin luther king
[Music]
it's a bad that's how [ __ ] white i am
because you know sometimes atlanta has
like atl
so i thought milwaukee was trying to be
cool like you remember like in the 2000s
there was that horrible time where
everybody
tried to give their city a nickname like
pittsburgh became the berg
cleveland was the land and the one of
the worst ever
boston i could remember you ever get
emails hell hey bill when are you coming
up to the bean
ugh i'm so glad that seemed like that
faded away
um anyway uh
so i thought that that's what milwaukee
was doing i thought that they were
stealing from atlanta
because you know atlanta's basically
considered a really cool place there's
all the
all the rap stars there hotlanta all the
beautiful women
all of this i mean it's a [ __ ] fun
place to go to right
so and then you know who gets excited
about milwaukee i do
i get excited about milwaukee because
i'm super white
i love milwaukee it's like chicago
without all the people
you can still get a wonderful home right
on lake michigan
and not have to deal with all the
[ __ ] prices down there in chicago
and you're close enough if you want to
go to chicago
you know you want to get [ __ ] up you
know you spend a little money for a
[ __ ] suv ride all the way down there
and yeah you're good to go
so anyways my apologies
my apologies i actually
i told that story to like three comedian
friends
that i knew i i course called keith
robinson and i had to let him know
and he oh my god he read me the riot act
i i don't have the message on me but
there was so many get it together bill
is what he kept saying to me so anyway
um the celtics lost another one so we've
lost to the pelicans
we blew up a 20-something point lead
then we lost to the
um and then we lost to the hawks
um and i got to tell you this is
becoming one of those times
where [ __ ] sports writers from the
east coast
what they love to do is [ __ ] over the
local home team
because they don't care about the local
home team they pretend like they do but
if you look at a lot of them they're not
from that area
so they're just writing sports [ __ ] so
their job is to stir
[ __ ] up and try to find controversy
where there is no controversy and then
they try to like
you know sell papers so get people to
read their [ __ ] blog
so i'm starting to feel like there's
gonna be people start asking like is
brad stevens the guy
he is the guy and i'm calling it right
now the celtics in the next five years
are gonna win a title
three to five years they're gonna win a
title um
and i have faith in danny ainge and brad
stevens it's just right now we're just
going through a rough patch just like in
life
you know sometimes you go through a
little bit of a rough patch
but you know you don't just [ __ ] quit
and join the [ __ ] warriors
you know or join the the yankees
and send david wells to the [ __ ]
toronto and then you start riding around
like you know like you just did
something
sorry um yeah you write it out you write
it out
um anyway so i've been reading this book
uh the verbally abusive relationship
and how to recognize it something like
that and i gotta be honest with you man
i picked up this book
um being like all right when i read this
book i'm just gonna be like yup
i know that person this is this person
in my life
when i was a kid yep yep that checks all
the boxes
i'm a victim right and i read that thing
and all i'm seeing is me
[Laughter]
um yeah i do a lot of the [ __ ] in there
i don't do it as bad as the people
before me but i still [ __ ] do it so
i uh it's really been this uh amazing
book
to read and like you know like whenever
you
i we did an episode about this on
episode family where you where
when you when you um say you confront
somebody
about some [ __ ] they did to you
right and
you know and you waited a while because
you know you didn't know how to maybe do
it in the moment
or you didn't even understand how [ __ ]
up it was and then you got some more
information
or somebody told you a story where
something happened to them and what they
did and all of a [ __ ] that happened to
me and i didn't say anything
so by the time you come to him what do
they always say what i never did that
are like oh that was just a joke oh
you're too sensitive
i didn't realize that that was being
like abusive because then you're like
gaslighting the other person
so one of the things that i i realize
that i do
is like my wife will be talking about
you know being in show business and
stuff
and how difficult it is and and that
they don't let you do this and they
don't let you do that and whenever i
hear it it makes me upset i'm just like
well
that's like the wrong way to look at
this [ __ ] they don't let me do this they
don't mean they
[ __ ] them [ __ ] everybody just go
do what you want to do and just keep
doing it and if it's good people will
notice they'll come there and when they
come there
everybody else will have to [ __ ] deal
with you
you know stop [ __ ] sitting there like
whining and [ __ ]
right it's me trying to be uplifting
so for years she told me she goes well
not everybody is wired like you
and um and i was like i wasn't wired
like me
when i came in you know i [ __ ] you
know i learned to be like that right
you know i kind of realized but reading
this book was just like well i wasn't
like
letting other people
go on the same journey it's just like i
already figured it out over [ __ ] 30
years in this business
get to where i am now or quit your
whining you know being like that
so interestingly enough last night has
been watching this show on pbs
where they take all these famous people
people in the public
eye socialites what have you whatever
the [ __ ] you call them
and um they they
do like their their dna thing
to find out like
you know about their ancestry right so
i'm watching it last night
and it was funny like they had this
this uh this white dude
i forget what his name i don't remember
anybody's name right so he's sitting
there
and the guy the host african-american
guy is reading him all this [ __ ]
and he's just going like wow
oh man that's i mean that's that's crazy
then they go okay at this point
you had you had a relative that got like
abducted
and uh during i don't want to get too
into this because you're going to figure
out who it is because i don't want to
make fun of these people but it was just
interesting me
that he never went deeper than wow
that's crazy
it was funny because i could kind of see
the host trying to pull emotion out of
him how does that make you feel he says
i mean that's just
i mean that i mean it's crazy
he sounded like you know you know those
douchey [ __ ] hipster ice cream places
where you go there and it's just like
this has
this has like lemon hall's uh peppermint
stick and it's just like why the [ __ ]
would you stick that in ice cream
try it they give you that little douchey
wooden spoon and everybody's like
oh that's interesting it's like watching
somebody do like do a [ __ ]
one of those reviews of a cigar i've
always spoken that
about that a lot i hate cigar reviews
like i'm getting hints of cocoa
there's some chocolate in there oh oh i
think a goat walked by this plant we get
it you have a sensitive palette just
smoke the thing you [ __ ] addict
you're just like me
so anyway um
so then they went and they did uh
pharrell williams they did his right
and with all the black people on the
show
they go it like it just immediately is
just obviously insane because of the
history they find out
with his they found out all the way back
to not only
his relatives that were slaves
there was a painting of the slave owner
and the guy goes all right
on the next page you're gonna see the
white man that owns your ancestors
and they turned the page and it was like
whoever painted this picture did not
like this guy
or this guy was truly the most evil
person on the [ __ ] planet i mean this
guy looked like
it looked like a painting from a haunted
house and he literally
had to like leave the interview
at one point and come back a month later
to finish it
and uh so i was watching that whole
thing
and i was just like wow this is and then
you listen to like white people go like
do the exact same thing from that
[ __ ] verbally abusive thing like oh
that was a long time ago
you know there was the potato famine you
know everybody went through stuff like
not
validating it and not giving any sort of
closure
and the whole thing just be like the
whole thing just that book and watching
that the whole thing came together so
um i don't know if you're a white person
in you're [ __ ] open-minded and you
actually want to try to learn
it was one of the most educational
things i've ever watched
um and i i don't know whenever i go
and i watch stuff like that anything
from watching kids bully kids to
like hardcore like concentration camps
slavery and all that i always say the
same thing i just say [ __ ] hate
people
um i don't know why i say that but i
just do
i just [ __ ] just the level the [ __ ]
that we are capable of and i'm throwing
myself in there too
is uh
is why i don't like there it is that's
why i don't believe in a higher power
i just don't that he would make human
beings
that or she you know you know what's
funny
is is is like this is the this is the
god
that when women go like god's a female
like that's a great argument oh yeah
so she's the one responsible for serial
killers and slave owners
[Music]
no our god is responsible for the
daffodils
um i guess there's something to say
about
the yen and the yang of good and evil a
good day versus a bad day because how
could you appreciate
stuff you know if everything was just
great all the time it would just be
normal
and you would sort of flatline
you know which is why the
concept of heaven never made sense to me
where it's just every day you're in
heaven it's like all right wouldn't that
get boring after a while
you never stub you don't even stub your
toe anymore just every day you're just
sitting there that's great i mean it's
great it's amazing
a thousand years [ __ ] days in is it
great yeah i told you it's [ __ ] great
oh here comes jesus again i got it buddy
you're happy that i'm here i'm happy to
be we're all happy
my [ __ ] face hurts from smiling
does it ever rain here um
yeah but i i you know now that i've
brought that up
i should give you the name of this thing
pbs show let me spike
pbs show ancestry
uh finding your roots
uh with henry louis gates
um i'm telling you and if you can
find the one uh the one that i was just
talking about
um i mean it it's it's ridiculously
moving
um and and unbelievably educational so i
highly recommend
that all right so plowing ahead
here let's talk about something positive
that i got to some of the uh
darkest behaviors of human beings
um so my kid right now is absolutely
she has the balance bike down it's and i
cannot
describe the feeling as a dad to see
your kid
learn how to balance on a bike because
she's not with the pedals yet but she's
just right there she's at the point
now we have a little hill in the
driveway she can go
from the hill in the driveway all the
way to the garage
which is probably like 30 yards and but
like literally last week all she could
do
is maybe like we you know we have like
the concrete so
there's like square concrete she could
go like a square and a half
and then the big squares right so i was
kind of doing like
you know this one of those things fell
off like
those little green things from a palm
tree fell off so i just
would put it down say hey you went this
far let's see if he can go
to this you know you just turn
everything into a game for him right
so um i took her to a couple of parks
where she could really just
go around and you know just played this
game
you know she likes me to like just
pretend like i'm talking and i'm hanging
out and all of a sudden she almost runs
over my toes and i flip out and i scream
like she's gonna run over and i
you know i get way in front of her and
then i stop i go you better stop don't
run over dad's feet she thinks it's the
funniest thing ever
and meanwhile she doesn't understand
that she's going faster and she's
starting to glide and all that stuff
because she's just laughing having a
good time right
so yesterday
the whole thing just clicked and i got
it on video
and everything and i swear to god
i'm telling you man it's it's the
greatest experience i've had
other than just literally becoming a dad
is seeing her figure that thing out the
look
on on a kid's face when they get it it's
like they learned how to fly it's
[ __ ] unreal
[Laughter]
so i'm now going to um
now what i have to do is the bigger bike
and what's so funny is look how
resistant on this little level i was to
change
where you can go back in my podcast when
i just go off
on the balance like this bike i bought
where it would not let you put
training wheels on it you know and they
were like
you know training wheels are actually
detrimental to blah blah blah blah
and i would and and the fact that they
took you know was is i just don't like
being controlled and i didn't
understand that the bike that i bought
because i didn't read
i was just like you know she wants a
blue bike blue there's blue bike buy
blue bike right
and then it comes i'm like oh what the
[ __ ] you know i didn't even read
anything just classic me classic b
classic me lashing out being verbally
abusive towards the balance bike people
with not even knowing what i'm bitching
about
um that's gonna be on my [ __ ]
headstone um
so now now i get it you just
you put the you take the pedals off the
[ __ ] thing it's a balance bike and a
bike you just don't have the pedals on
it so now i'm just gonna have her get on
that thing and what i have to teach her
now is uh is
the hand brakes she's got to learn how
to do that and like pedal and all that
but what's great is
with the balance bike is their instinct
when they start to tip over is to put
their feet down
which is the saving grace so the exact
thing that i was really yelling about
was i love my kid
i don't want her to fall down and get
hurt uh
was what i was really worried about and
as it comes out of me it's me screaming
yelling which of course makes you guys
laugh
so i can't totally cure that of me or
else this podcast will turn into that um
who's that character stuart smalley and
that's okay
so um i got a few days off here which i
can't believe
i'm just gonna hang with the family and
uh
do a little barbecue and um i'm gonna
see if i can get her on the uh the
bigger green bike i'm so freaking
excited for it but i'm also also trying
not to uh
rusher or anything like that so we're
gonna do a little drive
uh later on this weekend little family
drive
and uh i've gotten her into this
different kind of music
where if you want your kid to get into
ac dc and they're young
the song that really got her into it was
uh on dirty deeds
there's a song called uh dirty deeds
dunder chief is the album
the american album anyways and um
there's a song called uh i'm a rocker
it's a really fast
kind of silly song and it's crazy
energy and stuff and she always says
that she goes dad why ac dc sing so
crazy
why did why do you sing so crazy i was
just going well you know they're a
little nuts
they're banned you know that's that's
five lunatics and they go crazy and they
make 80 000 people go crazy every night
it's a great thing
so um
so i'm putting together a little
playlist for her
of you know nia has her music and i have
my music so
she's listening to you know i'm just
going like real simple basic rock stuff
so
it's 38 special hold on loosely
um ac dc
uh i'm a rocker and then i'm gonna have
her play uh i'm playing uh that
uh joan jett i love rock and roll
and uh i'm kind of hoping if she watches
a video because joan jett is like one of
the
you know most badass rock stars ever it
can
maybe make her interested in guitar or
whatever i'm just
you know i'm not forcing influences but
i'm definitely doing little passing
shots
shooting a few across the bow to see if
she turns her head and follows it we'll
see
um so i downloaded that song
and i never noticed that that song it's
it's
uh it's a really interesting song if you
listen to the production on it it's
first of all it's
it's three bars of four and then one bar
of three
um which i never noticed which is why in
the end when they're singing
they chop off a word i love rock and
roll
put another diamond that you box baby i
they skip one that's that's the that's
three which is basically
you're just taking one quarter note away
i guess i don't get those technical [ __ ]
but then if you also listen to the track
it
sounds like a drum machine it sounds
like uh uh
is it rick rubin who did all like the ll
cool j and um
beastie boys [ __ ] in the beginning it
sounds like
one of his tracks before he was making
music and i i would
was wondering if he was involved in it
or or
if he was too young because i remember
he kind of he made it real young like he
was at like nyu making beats and
everything and then
he was in that whole downtown village
tribeca scene and [ __ ] like i read that
bestie boys book like what
that whole part of new york used to be
like after dark it just seemed
like sort of this no-man's land of
like just young creative people and
um but anyways i think
if you listen to the track there's like
a number of things like almost like the
whole riff
sounds like a loop and if it isn't it's
incredible guitar playing because it
sounds so
everything even like joan jets ow that
she does sounds like the
like the exact same one they just kept
dropping it in
and i was talking to a buddy of mine
dave kushner
who does all the music for f is for
family and he goes
he goes no he goes i don't think because
back then they recorded on tape that
would have been really hard to do all of
that
but just have a listen there's something
about that song where it almost seems
it feels like one of those original um
as far as
the rap music that i heard in my
white cul-de-sac the first [ __ ] that i
heard
um it sounds like one of those tracks
with like rock guitar over it
um and i just thought it was just gonna
be like this simple song
and i was listening to it and i just
kept listening to it over and over i
started playing drums too like oh
whatever and then the beat turned around
like what the [ __ ] just happened there
i was like oh [ __ ] i never even noticed
that
i used to sing along to the song too and
towards the end we had to chop off uh
the role of rock and roll or whatever
the [ __ ] you have to do to get back on
the one
i never noticed that and then that's
like it's a genius [ __ ] track
because uh one of the big things
especially with any sort of like you
know a big record label was they want
basically wanted everything in four and
if you did anything in odd time
they would freak out being like no it's
not going to be a hit like that's going
to [ __ ] people up and they're not going
to know what's going on
so these these artists got so
would get so good at it that you know
some regular mouth breathing dope like
me wouldn't even notice that there was
one
bar of what's in this country considered
odd time anything that's not in four
um not saying that there's not songs in
three four but if they would have it in
three four
they they the whole song would be in
and everyone would just sort of sway and
it was always about like a [ __ ]
a ship you know what i mean
anytime like i don't know why anytime
[ __ ] there's some rule in music
anytime you would write a song
about being at c it had to be
you know
oh we'll blow the man down and then
that stupid [ __ ] piano mansion 3
[Music]
and all those baby boomers just swaying
back and forth pretending we're on a
boost boat
um and he said man what are you
doing here it was it's a really if
you're like a [ __ ] music nerd
like myself um
you should check it out oh another thing
too i forget the name of the
i think let me i i got one of the
coolest [ __ ] drum
books um and it's all of this [ __ ] that
uh it's all the [ __ ] that i've wanted to
learn history uh
let me see if this is right oh
here it is i got a killer drum book uh
get the break beat bible
um if you're just into like
any funk [ __ ] any sort of like um
all that cool ghost note [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] that came out of like
all the way back to little richard into
james brown
all of this stuff from the 70s
and then what hip-hop did with those
samples and all of that like this is the
[ __ ] book
to get and and it's like you can take
all of your influences
with this [ __ ] and and try to spin it in
some sort of different direction it's a
uh
an incredible book and recently
i've just sort of been listening to um
i love the 70s drum sound right
and um i've just been like
wanting to rather than go on like itunes
which is the one that i use
um
i i don't want to just go there and just
get like the like ohio players i've you
know been listening to them which was
always a frustrating band for me to
listen to because
i always they i just felt like the the
way they mixed the bass and the drums it
was so like on top of each other my ears
just weren't
good enough to um
you know to hear like what they were
doing and
the drummer this guy james diamond
williams is was
is an incredibly accomplished player and
was having like a jazz background
and he throws some [ __ ] [ __ ] in there
he's got a killer foot and he has
amazing uh
licks that he'll throw in that make no
sense as far as like
if you want to hit they usually don't
become like that complex but
anyway rather than just knowing like
the the hits like fire
or skin tight or whatever it's like i
want to go back and [ __ ] listen to
all the b-side [ __ ]
so i want to i want to get the albums
like i did that with joan jett it's like
i don't want to get i love rock and roll
off the greatest hits i want to get the
album that this came off off of a 1981.
um and i've been doing that with that
them and i also got into uh casey in the
sunshine band
and uh in just the way they marketed him
it was really interesting that the the
whole thing
so much of his stuff is just about
dancing
and [ __ ] it was just all like a party
and like how
that sort of like caught on like post
watergate post the vietnam war
everybody's just like let's just do some
blow
[ __ ] dance and bang each other and
just be whoever the [ __ ] you want to be
i don't know what but there's a cover of
this album i gotta see if i can find it
oh i think i downloaded it got it on my
phone it's one of the funniest [ __ ]
like
album album covers i've ever seen
where it looks like he's being rocketed
to the sky
right it's uh the name of the song i
downloaded was i i think one was que
pasa and the other was
do you want to go party and uh it's off
to a 1979 album i literally have to take
a picture of the album
this is how bad my eyes are now take a
picture of the album
why does it linger on the phone for so
long like i'm gonna do some photoshop
[ __ ] to it when are they gonna realize i
don't have those skills
okay do you wanna go party casey in the
sunshine band
and it's the lead singer whose last name
was casey
c-a-s-e-wife is first name was like
henry or herbert or something like that
saying why just go by casey
um he's sitting on like
a cork that's just popped off
a bottle right like like the the [ __ ]
sex metaphor here he's he's riding it
and there's a woman in front like right
in front of him
it looks like he's he's banging her but
they got clothes on
and uh he's obviously getting ready to
bust his nut right and he's
there's a big orange sort of i would
think the moon maybe that's a
weird night or something but looks like
the sun and he's shooting up
and this came out in 1979 right before
disco ended
and his career was going to take a
massive
change so it looks like he's being shot
into the stratosphere
i'm sure that's what they thought but
the way music history went he was really
being
just shot over the hill like you're it
like it's the
time for this music and this this band
it's time you know we're getting you out
of here you're being escorted out
and now all this [ __ ] new wave and
all this other shit's gonna come and
it's really interesting
um so anyway sorry i'm just babbling on
this [ __ ] podcast
i'm already 34 minutes in i haven't even
told you the story
about solo in a helicopter the other day
i had this [ __ ] great
flight like um i've gotten back into
trying to get my instrument rating i've
cleared all my schedule and i'm just i'm
[ __ ] doing it after this little
vacation here three-day thing here i'm
doing my family but
um so you know i'm a really
obviously cautious pilot and everything
and
um you know i like to be like
totally overly overly overly like ready
to solo but then
still do 10 more lessons with an
instructor
so that's where i was at right and it
was a nice day and i came up i
i pre-flighted the helicopter and i ran
to my instructor at the airport he was
hanging out with this other guy
and he goes so you're going to take it
out i'm solo tales like you know i don't
know i kind of got some stuff to do and
then the guys with he goes go do it
now's the time go do it get over the
hump or else you're never gonna do it
and i was like all right he's right he's
right you know i gotta get my confidence
up so
i went out you know the helicopter i fly
i have like a little four-wheeler and
it's on a
little helipad i take it out of the
hangar i bring it all the way out
and uh you know the big thing is for me
it's it's nothing about
taking off flying around and landing
it's that it's the helipad thing i
i my whole time flying i've always just
set it on the ground and the ground is
very forgiving it's the [ __ ] earth
it's kind of hard to miss the earth you
know when you set it down you're not
gonna
you can't fall off the earth as much as
flat earthers think you can
but when you're setting it on a helipad
there is a finite space
for you to put this thing in there's the
four-wheeler and the little tow hitch
and it's only like i mean it looks like
it's right there
like you're parking behind a [ __ ] car
and um when you get over the helipad
if you hover there too long
close to the pad what's called in-ground
effect is you swirl all the air and it
causes
the helicopter become unstable you got
to do a lot of stuff with your feet to
try to keep the tail straight you know
the nose pointed forward
and set it down what you really want to
do you know is just sort of be coming in
in this really really slow descent and
just almost like drive it onto it
so anyway i brought the thing out uh you
know i took my time i did the whole
pre-flight i did the whole thing just
made just meticulous i'm learning all
the names of the
parts all of this stuff i brought the
thing out
i got her fueled up you know i did
everything just did everything by the
book
and uh lifted her up
you know she went a little bit to the
left but i was able to recover it
quickly nothing crazy um
because i made sure that i got her light
on the skids and i sort of adjusted the
trim
so i could bring her up in a nice
controlled way
backed away from the pad you know i'd
already made my radio call
and was cleared for takeoff and i i
just sort of you know made sure my tail
was clear brought it over
took off from the actually taxiway
and i was off and i had this amazing
flight
flew all the way out to bracket
and uh which is just west of um
ontario and they had this little pad in
the north side and i just
went there and i just practiced pickups
and set downs and the first few were
rough and i just
kept picking it up doing a clearing turn
to the right and just setting it down
just over and over and over again until
i got it down where i could set it down
like a daisy
then i requested straight out departure
right and i [ __ ] went back
to the airport i had everything down i
was listening to the atis
because i have to go through an airport
airspace and then immediately
in the next airspace where i want to
land i won't have time the aetus is just
the information so you know what runway
where the winds are blowing and all that
[ __ ]
so um called the tower everything was
great i came in for a landing one
oh i know i [ __ ] up was i was
i got like all the latest technology on
this thing so i can actually
monitor while lists one frequency while
listening to the other
so i was going through the airspace of
one
um where i had to make the call to get
permission to transition their airspace
and i was listening to the atis of of
the airport because i wasn't going to
have time because the second i was out
of their airspace i'm in the other one
and i have to ask
for permission to land and i have to
tell them that i listen to the
information and i know what the [ __ ] is
going on right
so i was monitoring that which is a
great feature and when i when i was done
i then cleared out that
frequency and put in the frequency for
the next airport but what i didn't shut
off
was the monitoring
device so when i came into the airspace
of the place i was going to land i was
also still listening to the other
airports airspace and as i was cleared
to land i was coming in
and i heard them clear somebody to take
off
and it was the same numbers as the
runway and they were coming the other
way and i was like what the [ __ ]
but you know it was just for like half a
second and uh so i just
sort of cheated over to the uh
where the uh what do you call it i just
cheated over
to the taxiway just in case and then i'm
like oh i'm a [ __ ] idiot i was like
that was just this little half a second
thing but i stayed calm i figured it out
i also made the move in case
the uh air traffic controller for some
reason forgot that i was coming in and
he decided that you know the wind
changed that quickly that they'd be
coming at me
so um i was like okay learned that you
know you learned something every time
right so then i came in
landed and then i was like all right
here we go big boy time let's set it
down on the pad right
so i came in and because i did all of
that work i came in i just set it right
down the pad
everything went great and then you know
what's hilarious was i didn't have the
four-wheeler in gear
so me just sort of driving it on i i
landed on it and the four-wheeler
started to move
with the tr with the [ __ ] helipad and
me on it
like a jerk-off but you know the weight
of the helicopter stopped it like
immediately it only rolled like three
feet but i was sitting there going like
am i really gonna have to lift up back
off the helipad
set this [ __ ] thing down shut it off
go over put that [ __ ] thing in gear
i would have looked like a complete jerk
off but it's just [ __ ] that you learned
so
i had it in neutral just because it's an
old four-wheeler it's kind of that's the
only way it can start is if it's in
neutral it's a pain in the ass
and i'd put the the things to make sure
it didn't roll i put them under the
tires
of the four-wheeler rather than the
helipad and i learned that that was a
mistake because the four-wheeler cuz
can just roll right up and over him so
other than that
it went great and uh this story is
really just for other pilots out there
because everybody else you know
they're gonna be like you're gonna
[ __ ] die all this dumb [ __ ] that they
say
and one of the great things i ever
learned it said that basic aviation is
it's as safe as you
are so i know i made a couple mistakes
there but it was wasn't like major [ __ ]
um it's more like you know if you're not
going to pre-flight something
and you're not going to look at tfrs and
you're not going to [ __ ] see what the
weather is you're just going to go out
there
you know and then fly like a [ __ ]
idiot and not
you know basically do all the [ __ ] they
told you not to do yeah you're not gonna
have a good day but i can tell you this
without a doubt having someone who's
done both there's nothing more dangerous
than driving down the [ __ ] highway
in los angeles it's absolutely [ __ ]
terrifying
terrifying and i know that they have all
this crazy technology now but if you
look what the [ __ ] happened to tiger
woods
i mean that could just happen um
and it's like you're up in the air
there's nobody up there i mean there's
people up there but
i can actually see where the [ __ ] they
are and we're all talking to each other
it's infinitely more safer i can't even
tell you about how much
safer do you pre-flight your [ __ ] car
before you [ __ ] go drive it before
you drive
in 80 90 miles an hour in the left lane
and what if your [ __ ] engine just
quit and then you're sitting there
and there's some douche right behind you
you know i don't know i just think the
probability
of getting hurt it's my own thing i just
hate that i have to defend such a fun
thing to do
um all right let's do uh what do we got
here uh
liquid death we got a new this is not
booze this is the exact
opposite all right sad fact if we don't
get plastic production under control
plastic pollution will outweigh fish by
2050.
i'm going to read that again how crazy
it is if we don't get plastic pollution
under control plastic pollution will
outweigh fish
by 2050. okay you want to talk about an
abusive relationship is these
corporations what they're doing to the
environment
and and and their [ __ ]
foot on everybody's goddamn throat i
don't know what their end game is
they for some reason cannot see beyond
the next quarter
um anyways by now everyone knows you're
supposed to drink lots of water
do we do it no i certainly don't
so many of us go through life dehydrated
by the time you feel thirsty you've
needed water for a while
um look at that i just had a weird
hiccup there you'd eat it for a while
feeling thirsty chug one
liquid death actually helps you drink i
heard you're not supposed to do that
like you're not supposed to just chug
the water you're supposed to you know
but i guess they're liquid dead you
[ __ ] chug your [ __ ] liquid death
actually helps you drink water
uh easier to chug no more cap so you
just have to finish it
this is these guys are like militant in
their [ __ ] belief that you need to
drink water
um well don't you see a bunch of bottled
waters not finished with no cap on it
and there's a cap sitting next to it
i don't know if you guys i like that how
committed these guys are to getting you
know these women or whoever to get you
hydrated uh the water is a hundred
percent
mountain water from the alps none of
that
processed tap water like most of the
major bottling brands
tapped at the sources purified while
keeping a hundred percent of the
original mineral profile
by minerals we mean electrolytes also
electric lights are an actual thing
uh that the kind that murder your thirst
instantly the brand death to plastic
um oh so these guys
you know they're getting you hydrated
and they're against plastic i [ __ ]
love these guys
we need more companies like these guys
this is
this righty you know what i like about a
company like this this gives me [ __ ]
hope
all right because you can't face
corporations head-on you got to go
covert you got to come from underneath
you need to support a new
company like this so now you know what's
gonna happen all these plastic
corporations they're gonna start
circling they're gonna start throwing
mountains of coke [ __ ] and money at
these guys to try to buy their [ __ ]
brand
um get it at whole foods 7-eleven
or if you've been to texas recently you
can get it at walmart
um joke about how the can looks like a
beer well it does
it does it looks like uh i don't know
what i've spent so long since i drank
for some reason i'm thinking natty
light there uh get two free cookies with
your first order of any case of water at
liquid death dot com slash burr
just hit up their merch store add the
koozie
oh you get two free koozies it's like
why are they writing cookies with the k
this thing was spelled k-o-o-k-i-e-s
it's koozies
add the koozie two-pack you want and you
get it free
with your first case well that's a two's
koozie
i know what the [ __ ] cookies and koozies
you're getting something only at
liquiddeth.com i'm getting that [ __ ]
i'm getting that [ __ ] all right
i was actually trying one year when i
went on the road to try to not drink any
more
plastic bottles of water and i was
bringing my thermos out there because i
was thinking the places i was performing
at would have a bubbler
or at least the hotel um to try and
lessen my
like you ever lined up all the bottles
of water that i drank and probably
didn't finish
on acting gigs and [ __ ] uh
other things like that um wow
i would be uh yeah
i think at this point we all need to go
out in the ocean and take some of our
plastic back
what do you do with it i was always
thinking that it'd be amazing if you
could just
somehow get all of the pollution that
we've created
right and just put it on a spaceship and
then
send it towards the sun
but then you know what happened would it
would burn up
and there would be like this [ __ ]
this gas
and it would just be out there and the
scientists would be like
there is a one and four billion chance
that by september of next year
sorry i just watched uh doctor
strangelove once we will come through it
we will breathe in all of our old
plastic water bottles
this could cause craziness all right i
have to get out of here i gotta go
back inside all right so that's it you
guys uh
let's see what did i recommend yeah the
break beat bible if you're a drummer
uh in the pbs show ancestry and uh
what was that i'll give you the name of
that book that i'm reading which is
really helping me out
it was funny i thought i was going to
get to blame a bunch of people and i'm
actually realizing i
i i have yet more work to do on myself
the verbally there it is
it's called the verbally abusive
relationship i got the expanded edition
because i'm really [ __ ] up
[Music]
the third edition for any other lunatics
out there all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourself have a great weekend
you [ __ ] and uh
that's it i'll talk to you later go
bruins go celtics go [ __ ] yourself
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
february 25th
2013. how's it going
um i'm still in boston my my record is
still [ __ ] up so just bear with me
there's gonna be one more week but i
promise i plugged in my laptop so there
won't be the fan sound this week
at least i got rid of that right it's uh
snowing out here i'm sitting in a hotel
room
i got the oscars on in the background
not because i want to watch them
nia was just watching him i told her to
go downstairs to the bar while i do this
um i'd like to have her on the podcast
but it's going to sound like [ __ ]
sounds like [ __ ] with one person forget
about two um
i don't know i don't know i just you
know i was all psyched to do this stupid
podcast
and i had the sound down on the tv and i
saw barbra streisand
and i was like holy [ __ ] is she singing
i know she notoriously has stage fright
she doesn't like to do it
so i turned it on and she was singing
that song memories
which is uh who's kitten who it's one of
the most depressing [ __ ] songs you're
ever going to listen to
really just affected my mood um
barbara if you're listening to this
could you please stop singing that
[ __ ] song
memories when we all used to be
young a lot of our dreams didn't happen
and now we're gonna die
right i [ __ ] do not like sad songs
like that
i don't mind individual pain oh speaking
of songs
uh i read you know i've known about that
dude bruno mars for a while i just i
listened to a little bit of his [ __ ] but
you know i'm an old man
i can't relate to somebody singing about
the prime of their life
i mean i i lived through the prime of my
life at least i hope i did
well maybe i hope i didn't which means
it would get better at some point and
then barbra streisand wouldn't be
[ __ ] bumming me out
with their goddamn depressing songs it
was annoying she always sings it with
the most sparkly [ __ ] dress on
they should rename that song put a gun
in your mouth
[Laughter]
oh jesus look how old richard gere is
now it's just i don't need this he just
told me [ __ ] ernest borgnite died
which i didn't even know half the people
who are dying made movies when i was a
kid now
which means the that [ __ ] grim reaper
uh sickle
is right on my ass i don't need to see
that i don't even see that somebody who
did something on et just died
or some guy who made the [ __ ] shark
fin and jaws died
well i guess maybe i do that guy should
get he should get his uh he should get
his due
right you guys hear me typing here i
just remember i needed to talk about
something
that that guy should get is due without
[ __ ] you know without a doubt but i mean
i i don't i just find it really
depressing
you know i don't know anyways
the hell am i talking about i'm i'm here
in boston and uh
oh this is gonna be a rough one people
this is gonna be a rough one once again
once again talking into my [ __ ]
laptop this is bizarre to me
um i'm out of my comfort zone there
there i said it
you know i haven't watched all the
oscars did they did they do that stupid
moment they do every year where they go
movies they allow us to dream
they allow us to look at life
differently they allow us to
see a future where things are better
they allow us not to have our balls
sticking to our legs
in the summertime if you don't have air
conditioning it's great to go in the
theater
um i actually didn't see a lot of the
movies this year
jesus look at the [ __ ] ass on her
um anybody else notice nicole kidman did
too many of those those shoulder shrug
exercises what the [ __ ] was going on
with her
she literally had cornerback just in the
neck though is that pilates
pilates like um that's one good thing
that we got out of the inquisition
didn't we is we got that little pilates
stretcher rack there
how [ __ ] up was the inquisition huh a
bunch of people going around torturing
you till you say that you believed
in the bearded baby you know is it any
wonder i
why i left that religion ah
who's kidding who i didn't want to get
up that [ __ ] early
um anyways i had a huge huge week
uh before i really get going here i want
to thank everybody who uh
came out to the patrice o'neill benefit
on tuesday night
uh it was an unbelievable
success and it was so great to finally
send
send him off the right way and i i gotta
tell you
um everybody on the show was hilarious
and
i really felt that people stepped it up
and were just going above and beyond um
[Music]
like keith robinson was the funniest
i've ever seen him
colin quinn jim norton david tell
everybody crushed ian edwards was was
great
just because uh you know he does a lot
of writing and i think
not enough people know what a phenomenal
comedian he is uh rich foss hosted bobby
kelly
jumped on the grenade came out first
wilson vince who else did i miss
somebody in there i probably missed
somebody and they're going to get upset
but um it was such a success um
i i'm not going to i hope that we get to
do it again
because it was great to see all those
guys and everybody of course was
backstage
and everyone some people wore suits
other people didn't so immediately there
was a hatfields and mccoy
going on in the green room so everybody
was getting trashed
norton took a nice pounding poor guy got
himself in shape he thinks he's looking
good but
evidently he bought a suit when he was a
little more pudgier so everyone was
trashing him about that
and uh you know i caught some [ __ ] from
my big head you know the usual the usual
sort of
oh the tit for tat that went on
backstage but um i want to thank
everybody who came out
um it um it really was
an awesome night and uh i feel
very thankful that all you guys who
bought tickets
came out and see people about the
posters and that type of thing and i'm
really hoping that we can do it again at
some point i have no idea when
next year two years i have no idea but
it was too fun
to not at least consider maybe doing
again all right so there you go
all right back to the podcast here
i've already started this thing a couple
of times i forget if i already brought
this up but uh tom papa has joined the
wonderful world of all things comedy
podcast network that i started with al
madrigal
he's going to be taping a new stand-up
special and there's free tickets
available if you're in the new york area
he's going to be at the uh the skirball
did i already do this i probably already
did
but i'm going to do it again it's at the
skirball on march
7th we'll put the link up there i don't
remember did i already do it i probably
already did it
not jesus christ anyways brown i was
talking about singers
so bruno mars was this guy that you know
i knew he was a talented kid or whatever
but like i said you know a lot of his
songs was about being young and going
out and partying that whole
being in your 20s and that type of thing
and uh you know i'm an old bastard
i mean i think i'm closer to neil
young's age than i am bruno mars but uh
i don't know what i was doing i was
clicking going through the internet and
i saw him sing on that show the voice
uh which had i known it was the voice i
wouldn't have watched it because i don't
like that show
i don't like how they all sit there with
their [ __ ] backs to the singer
and they're lazy boys and then they hit
the button and they turn around that's
supposed to be like
exciting for me as the viewer you know
like my life is that sad and pathetic
not saying it's not sad and pathetic but
you know you got to do more than spin
around in a [ __ ] lazy boy to get me
going all right
but anyways he goes on that show
sang this song when i was your man
absolutely [ __ ]
crushes it watched it like 10 times
so this whole week i'm up at the uh the
wilbur theater and i'm working with uh
the sensation joe derosa and i keep
telling him about it he keeps breaking
my balls
saying that i like this [ __ ] teen
idol and all that type of thing and i
just wouldn't let it up
i finally made him sit down and watch it
last night when we were hammered
he got through it and then i took an
unbelievable pounding from him and nia
that i actually like it but you know
what i stand by it
i don't give a [ __ ] if you guys give me
a rough you know what i was excited
about is the fact that there's there's
somebody young out there who could
actually just go out there with a piano
player
and just sing you know
those djs they i i don't you know i've
already talked about that on kona and i
i don't
i don't [ __ ] get what's going on
there
you know [ __ ] kanye west
guy does a whole song use a whole album
using uh auto-tune he can't even sing
and even worse he goes out on [ __ ]
tour
and people are paying tickets to watch a
guy sing who can't [ __ ] sing
without like singing through like this
iron lung or some [ __ ]
and they're paying like a hundred bucks
to sit in the front row to watch
somebody who can't even [ __ ] sing
it was just you know it made me feel
good to see somebody just come out there
and absolutely [ __ ] crush it like
that so
um i've been joking with neos like i got
to go see this dude
live and i have to bring you because
it's going to be a bunch of [ __ ]
teenage girls and then my old ass is
going to be standing there
i'm going to get arrested but uh
i don't know it was a great thing to uh
it's a great thing to see
you know when you get old what happens
is
is [ __ ] changes and because you're
grumpy
you don't think anything's better is
this too [ __ ] loud am i blowing
myself out here
it's like a goddamn heart attack here in
the mixer um
no when you get old like [ __ ] changes
some [ __ ] changes for the better
you know hair transplants are way better
[Laughter]
some medicine is better but a lot of
other [ __ ] suffers
cars all look the same i guess they're
better as far as their handling and
safety and [ __ ] but you know
some [ __ ] was better people could sing
back in the day
so it's nice to see somebody they can
all right jesus christ you think i'm
drunk here
that's actually two positive things i've
said in a row that never happens on this
podcast
um all right you know what i'm i'm
actually
upset that i missed and happy that i
missed was
uh women fighting in the ufc
i i just there's just something there's
just something so wrong about that
you know to be just sitting there taking
[ __ ] kicks to your womb
i mean you you're women you're supposed
to be better than that you're supposed
to
be able to solve your [ __ ] problems
you know by by i don't know pulling each
other's hair
i don't want to see some girl take a
kick to her titties it's just and
grounding and pounding
their pretty faces that there really is
to i don't know i don't want to get used
to seeing that
you know it's kind of like when you
first start watching porn
second a girl bends over doggy style
you're like holy [ __ ]
that's amazing you know it's incredible
then after a while
it doesn't do anything for you you got
to go to the next level i don't want to
do that with fighting
i want to keep it like you know i can
watch two guys beat the [ __ ] out of each
other i really don't want to see two
women
kick the [ __ ] out of each other so but
on the other side i think it's a great
thing
that women can fight like that i i
actually have a solution
i might bring this up to rogan if i if i
get to do his podcast
um or if i ever bring him on this one if
i stop being so [ __ ] lazy and
actually have a guest every once in a
while
uh i have a solution i think that those
wit the women of the ufc rather than
fighting each other
they should fight uh convicted rapists
right just hear me out you take them out
out of the
and they don't know they don't know wait
that's weird is that too much if the
rapist doesn't know that he's got to
have a
a pay-per-view fight that he's going to
be involved in it
um i would ever give the rapist a
fighting chance here's the deal you go
in there
you fight the broad and uh if you if
if she wins everyone's going to be happy
if the rapist wins then what
he gets to go free he can't let him go
what does he get
a couple cartons of cigarettes
dude you know how [ __ ] how much
you're an [ __ ] you'd have to be to
root for the rapist
because that's a [ __ ] up thing like
vegas would be then taking odds so at
some point
they would have to make just you know
because money vegas always wants money
on both sides of the ball
they would have to make it so [ __ ]
enticing that you'd have to bet the
rapist
just so they could offset everybody who
doesn't want to bet on
on a rapist right i don't know i'll to
get back to you on that one i'll have to
work that one out
as far as how that would work out did
anybody watch it can you send me some
emails
because i really don't want to see that
i've seen it in boxing a couple times
and some girls just sort of jab together
throwing out a
stiff jab and just punches the girl
right in one of her breasts
and this there's just something wrong
about it
[Laughter]
you know a low blow
she had a baby man you know you can't
it's just
i don't know it was funny some women
actually get mad at them
with their their constant quest to be
doing everything that men do
and never really stepping back to
consider whether
what we're doing is stupid or not they
just want to [ __ ] do everything that
we're doing so they can feel like that
they are
they are free charlize theron what do
you think about that haircut
that wayne gretzky in 1988
she should be up there [ __ ] accepting
the heart trophy
i you know it's funny but when she was
on the uh the red carpet
she said uh they asked her about her
haircut
and she said the same thing every chick
says that has short hair she goes oh my
god it's so
freeing it just it's just every woman
should do it and i'm thinking like no
they shouldn't
for my own selfish reasons you know you
don't need to get the ethel haircut
that young in your life that's really
what that is
that basically you get that haircut
you're basically saying
you know i don't care if my husband
wants to [ __ ] me or not we're we're
legally bound here
i got enough years in by all means go
[ __ ] somebody else i
i really don't care at uh
oh my god you know something like i've
noticed that with my in marriages that
that's that's a moment in the marriage
when the woman when i'm sure some people
can send me some emails
when your wife cuts off all her
beautiful hair
i got it so easy i just wash and go you
know
right then when a woman gets a haircut
that short it's like doggy style becomes
a really weird position
you know depending on their hair color
they can all of a sudden look like one
of your friends
you know all right i'm really going off
on the women here i'm really putting you
guys in a box no pun intended
all right i don't think you should fight
in the ufc unless you're fighting
rapists
and uh i don't think that you should get
the uh
mabel haircut until you're i don't know
that should be the menopause haircut hot
flashes i can't have my teenage hair
anymore
it's making my brows sweaty i think that
that's when you should cut it off
do you know they always do they always
i don't know then they always have to
still [ __ ] tease it in some way
it's like why don't you just just just
part it on the [ __ ] side
if you're just gonna go out and go out
and get like a steve carell haircut
then you should comb it like him steve
corral that's a bad that's a bad
reference
who has just a george clooney
you know jesus bill are you judging
enough people here or what yeah i
am i am what are you gonna do about it
all right clicking here on here i know
this is making a ton of noise i don't
know what to tell you
i got some advertising here i gotta read
all right everybody
where is it where is it legalzoom
everybody
legal zoom are you waiting for the
perfect time to start your dream
business
well it's right now legalzoom the
official sponsor of the national start
your business month wants you to get
started right now
uh whether you're setting up an ls llc
an s corp
sole proprietorship or a non-profit
legalzoom takes care of you from start
to finish
their award-winning service was
developed by the best legal minds in the
country
every business gets personalized
attention that's why over ninety percent
of legalzoom customers would recommend
the service to their family you'll be in
good company three dozen companies on
the inc
i guess that's inc 500 lists were
started through legal zoom
um wow man that's actually 36 of them
for those you can't add um it's national
start your business month so start your
business right at legalzoom.com
legalzoom is not a law firm and provides
self-help services at your specific
direction so if you need help ask them
but there's so much more
now every llc an incorporation package
includes easy to use business accounting
software
a 269 dollar value absolutely free be
sure to enter bur
bur in the referral box at checkout
start your business protect your family
and safeguard your assets at legalzoom
today
all right and after you've started your
business
oh [ __ ] quentin tarantino won an oscar
oh that's awesome good for him
best original screenplay he looks good
too
he's got a leather tie there he is he's
got to have something in there that he's
a maverick
ah that makes me happy good for him all
right
stamps.com everybody um
do you want to do everything you can do
at the post office and the safety of
your own home
safety of your own apartment um in your
little tent city ustamp.comstamps.com
everything you would do with the post
office you can do right from your own
desk
buy and print official us postage for
any letter package
using your own computer or printer
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
calculates the exact postage you need
for any class of mail you'll never have
to go to the post office again
or even lease one of those expensive
postage meters
i use stamps.com to send out all my dvds
i never have a problem
it's made my life a lot easier and i'm
so dumb if i can figure it out so can
you
right now use my last name burr burr for
a special offer no risk trial plus 110
dollar bonus
offer includes a digital scale and up to
55 dollars
free postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burr
burr that stamps.com enter bur
that was pretty good read i got to admit
i was reading that and watching a very
excited
quentin tarantino sorry i leaned back
[ __ ] forget the microphones right here
oh it's going to be so uneven um
where the hell are we
oh jesus i'm sorry guys this is this is
even for me
this is a level of unprofessionalism
um did i mention tom papa yet
[Laughter]
you know what sucked today aside from
the fact that it was doing that annoying
not raining not snowing
and blowing horizontally right in your
face i really do not miss the winter by
the way
i do not miss this [ __ ] at all i want to
go right back out to los
angeles and breathe in that nice warm
smog that i've really gotten accustomed
to
um what do we got here i you know the
bruins are on today and i have the
uh i have the whatever the center rice
package whatever you call it on my
computer and but because it was a local
game
it's blacked out on my computer and i'm
in a hotel and they don't have nessen so
i didn't get to watch it but i did see
the clip
of zadino charo's 360
backhand goal you know let's see john
scott do that buffalo fans hey buffalo
fans did you see did you see what's his
face said john scott shouldn't even be
in the league
i literally sound like a school girl
even jeremy roenick doesn't like him
um i can't wait till we play
the sabers again and i can't wait till
we play
the stupid canadians you know what i
love about the canadians
is their thrilled trying to walk around
like they're the kings of the league i
mean
last time the canadians won a stanley
cup
white people loved oj simpson
okay white people's last time they won
it
it was a year before white people were
like oh my god
oj is a monster you know and black
people too but only amongst themselves
they're not allowed to admit it to white
people
that's how long it's been and they still
walk around
oh it's so embarrassing when you go up
to this stupid
this stadium there right as you go in
all they got all their stanley cups
you know which i'm sure is a great idea
when they built the place because they
probably thought there's no [ __ ] way
we're going to go on a
you know decade upon decade drought here
because they're not winning it this year
you know they're not and if uh
you know if they win it this year um
i'm actually gonna lobby no if they if
they straight up win i don't give a [ __ ]
but if
i've i haven't watched too many of their
games but if they're playing that trap
defense like i heard
um like that canadians rangers game
where the the coach of the ranger said
it was one of the worst hockey games
he's ever seen just completely boring
i don't understand for the life of me
why the nhl just doesn't make that an
illegal defense
if basketball the nba is smart enough to
be like listen guys are too big and too
fast
you've come up with the defense that is
just far too effective
it's so cutting down the scoring it's
affecting the entertainment value of the
product
that's an illegal defense you can't do
it anymore i don't know why
they just haven't made the [ __ ] thing
illegal
it's the worst it's the [ __ ] worst
all you do is just sit there watching
the other team just dumps it in the
whole game
you know and the other team just sits
there waiting for you to make a mistake
and it's it's literally it's like i
don't know what it's like watching
it's i can't even say a pictures duel
because a pictures duel is exciting
watching
if they're mowing people down there's
still great plays being made like
exciting stops in the field
you know somebody's got a no hitter
going that can be exciting
no scoring and hockey i can't even say
no scoring it no rush is on the net
you know i think that basic you know the
forward should all be required
i mean i guess you know i guess i don't
the trap is there they are for checking
it's just it's too [ __ ] effective
[Laughter]
i don't know who came up with it but
it's perfect i was actually
i'll give you a link to it for you guys
who aren't hockey fans if you watch it
it's really phenomenal so
i it's just they people just can't i was
watching one youtube video and the guy
was saying he had a system that could
beat it but
i don't think he does or somebody in the
nhl would be doing it
you know what i like to do people i like
to have a microphone that i lean away
from
talking about the most obscure of the
top four sports
and breaking down the defenses because i
feel that that's going to be that's
going to be interesting for the fans
um all right let's let's get let me at
least for the love of god
get to a goddamn letter here uh this is
from mexico
um hola hombre sorry um first of all i'm
a huge fan of yours from mexico
if i was a newscaster i would have been
first of all i'm a huge fan of yours
from mexico
um i love your stand up i love when you
are on kona thank you very much
thanks for all keep it up thank you all
right
that was it oh that was the whole letter
oh i'm sorry i love you stand up i love
when you are at
conan and most recently i loved the
boots you were rocking at your latest
appearance
so if possible could you share what
brand
what brand are those where the [ __ ] are
they you know what i have them hang on a
second i'll go get them
i'll go get them for you oh my god what
a podcast
just amazing they are
coming back with the shoes i gotta be
honest with you
me amigo from mexico um i got these when
i was in stockholm sweden
i had to get something they are uh
christ my [ __ ] eyes are going i tell
you that
i tell you that my [ __ ] eyesight's
going you know pissed me off
as i was hanging out with uh opie from
the opium anthony show
and he asked me one day he goes dude
have you your eyes starting to go yet
i go no my eyes are fine he goes he's
like they will bro
they will he's always doing that [ __ ]
your shoulder hurt
no no it doesn't wait we wait you wait
it's gonna
and i'm like why does he think that all
of his ailments are gonna hit me it's
not an age thing it's how you lived your
life
you know we have two totally different
bodies
why would you say that to me and the
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] was right about
my eyes wasn't right about the shoulder
all right they're called uh
rizzo it's either rizzo or or
pizzo i think it's rizzo all right zzo
i got him in sweden though a couple of
years ago
and god knows they probably stopped
making them because that's what they do
right
they start making clothes everybody
loves them and then they get rid of them
they got to get some new ones
you hear these right here you know what
that's the sound of an
almost empty tin of bootleg
bootleg [ __ ] m m's these things
there's something wrong with them
i can't stop eating it but they're
disgusting
totally ripped off m m's they look just
like them except they don't have the m
on them
all right this is from ireland ireland
in the new world order
dear billafor i've been a huge fan of
your podcast for years now
and think your advice is pretty [ __ ]
great thank you in fact listening to one
of your podcasts help me leave a shitty
toxic
relationship look at this oh billy
redface helping people out
and i've been lucky enough to meet a
fantastic woman since hey buddy it could
be more happy for you
could have been happier for you anyways
he says
enough blowing smoke up your arse i love
when people do that i didn't ask you to
do it
and i helped you out with the most
important thing in your life so go [ __ ]
yourself
anyways he said i'm from ireland and
that country is pretty much
owned by the european banks now and no
longer a sovereign state
essentially was taken down economically
economically and everyone is in debt now
i live in britain
and now they are voting on having secret
courts and all kinds of terrifying
orwellian [ __ ]
secret courts oh my god
so it does seem we are skipping towards
the new world order
my question is on population reduction
how do you think the new world order are
going to going to take us
all out also when you say you understand
why they want to do this what about the
fact that they want
to turn who's left into slaves
um i don't condone it but i mean that is
pretty much uh the history of human
beings
you know i mean we're all unbelievably
lucky
to be living right now as free people
you know because we really think about
yourself what do you you know what are
you bringing to the table
you know i don't know i can't talk for
you but i'm certainly not royalty
i haven't invented anything um
so why shouldn't i be out there picking
up heavy [ __ ] for smart people
that's probably one of the dumbest
things i ever said but i i get i don't
know
i just i i don't have any faith in human
beings i just think that uh
there's a select few
that are decent and i'm not including
myself when i say that and i just don't
feel that um
i don't feel that people handle power
they can't handle it you know and that
even goes for regular
people a lot of people [ __ ] on you know
the rich
uh they're [ __ ] [ __ ] and they act
like they're better people but i mean
if if you just look at what the people
what people do on the internet when they
just have the power of being anonymous
how
[ __ ] mean that they are and you know
i know some people just troll them but a
lot of people they just you know
they're [ __ ] they're like holy [ __ ]
i can say whatever i want
not get in trouble for it and they just
immediately just say the meanest [ __ ]
they could possibly say
you know i i think that if you actually
got a position of power where you could
do something else you you'd probably
abuse that too
so anyways how do i think they're gonna
take us all out i don't know
i cell phones cell phones they're
probably just cooking our brains
i have no idea
i i would think that they would do the
usual [ __ ] divide
divide you you you basically um
say that these people are better than
these people these people are out to get
us
yadda yadda yadda i don't know
but you know it has to be done
[Laughter]
people do you think we're just going to
keep having more and more people and
eventually
this [ __ ] isn't going to hit the fan do
you honestly think that there can be
seven billion people on the planet we're
not affecting
the planet you know imagine if there was
seven billion deer in this planet and
for some [ __ ] up reason
for like a four year period they all
really got into rollerblading
did i use this analogy yet i can't
remember let's just say they all really
got into rollerblading then after four
years it was considered gay
and they all got they just threw out
their rollerblades
threw them into the [ __ ] ocean
i mean it would just be open season on
deer they're like these [ __ ] deer are
the
biggest [ __ ] ever um
yeah we're out of control a lot of
control and a lot of tough decisions are
going to have to be made
and uh
i get i don't know what to tell you
i find though i find it all funny though
uh i've gotten beyond the scary
scariness of it i got beyond the
depression of it
and uh something's gonna happen look if
if they're not actually um
look if somebody isn't out there trying
to take over the whole world then
humanity has been wiped off the planet
there's always going to be somebody out
there trying to do that [ __ ] but uh
i don't know i think if we keep [ __ ]
and having kids and all that type of
[ __ ]
uh i don't think we're gonna have to
worry about the new world order doing
anything to us i think mother nature
will swiftly or slowly i don't know
they'll handle it
there's only so many fish yeah you want
to kill all of them yeah
see how that works out you know
melt the [ __ ] ice caps drown us very
easy
very easy to get rid of us a couple of
storms do i sound crazy
well maybe i am i don't give a [ __ ]
um cheater at the wilber
um hey bill i saw you uh i was at your
late show
last night and before i get into it but
i had a great time all right
anyway about 20-30 minutes before the
sensation joe derosa took the stage
by the way joe derose is taping his
half-hour comedy central presents
right here in boston on tuesday night
and uh comedy central they're giving out
free tickets
so why don't you guys go down and
support my boy i really appreciate it
if you're busy i understand a couple you
show up
be a nice thing um anyways about 20 to
30 minutes before the sensation took the
stage
he was great by the way i was sitting
next to this fairly attractive woman
up in the mezzanine she took one look at
this usher and you could tell her [ __ ]
got wet and she wanted him
jesus dude you were really paying
attention to this um
she started talking to him and hitting
on him and eventually
settling on a time and day to get
together with him and they exchanged
phone numbers about five minutes after
this
exchange i was admittedly a little
jealous of this guy
until the lady's husband came and sat
down with her
he was definitely her husband and at
first it was a little uncomfortable for
me
especially when she gave me a you better
keep your mouth shut or i'll stab you
look dude did this really happen or did
you dream this
who would just [ __ ] openly cheat like
that i don't know if i believe this
but after a couple of minutes i saw the
irony of it when i thought
she's here to see bill burr a comedian
who is famous for his anger towards
these [ __ ]
and i started dying laughing right in
the middle of the theater
when it wasn't even half full yet which
got me a couple of stares from people
the hell i thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious and this woman had no clue
what i was laughing at
which made it even better and i started
laughing harder anyway
love the podcast and i will see you
again in hampton soon
um yeah look
i hope that didn't i hope the way you
were reading that
it didn't go down that way but uh
you know i've been on the road a long
time boys and girls
and that look at robin de niro looks
like he's gonna fall asleep
um i've been on the road a long time
and uh yeah i you you'd be amazed how
married women behave
it's [ __ ] ridiculous and you know and
it's not all of them
basically what it is the decent people
after the show
they go home you know why because
they're happy with their lives
they're happy with who they're with they
got kids they got a job
they want to get back to their life it's
the people who hang out afterwards
unless you're young and in your 20s but
i'm saying
there's people who are married and they
still [ __ ] hang out they're still
searching they're still seeking
you know and uh [ __ ] happens
people oh my god is meryl streep that
[ __ ] old
ah um you know what i'm gonna shut this
off
i can't [ __ ] watch this [ __ ] anymore
she looks like i cannot
say that it's too mean
she's like a first lady she looks like a
first
lady uh does she get by the way does she
get nominated every year
she has to go down like people are
always talking about like deniro pacino
uh marlon brando and that type of thing
you gotta throw her in there
she's gotta have the most nominations
ever
um isn't that unbelievable
let's let's let's just play along with
this thing here and let's just say that
that's true
like how long was this guy gone for
man it had been pretty she takes one
look at this guy starts shooting the
[ __ ]
and they're talking loud enough that you
hear it and they exchange phone numbers
i don't know well i mean i've i've seen
uh
i've seen worse things
i'm at one time uh i was on the road
you know drinking with some people
afterwards there was this married couple
and the [ __ ] wife in the end we all
go to say goodnight say goodnight to
husband she comes up
and i'm standing there and she basically
puts her clam on my [ __ ] leg
just like walks right into it
it was it was you know it
was just like your husband's right over
there
you got your goods on my leg what are
you doing
and i'd like to tell you that that only
happened one [ __ ] time
you know the deal women are smart with
their dirt
they keep it in-house i think they just
talk about it amongst themselves
but uh and then they got that great
thing that even when they cheat it's
it's always because the oh the guy
wasn't uh
wasn't giving me what i needed but blah
blah blah blah it's like well yeah
that's why guys cheat too
you know you weren't bringing another
woman into the bedroom so i could have a
threesome
yeah you know
i don't [ __ ] enough and you know be
[ __ ] unreal is what if your wife was
one of those
ufc chicks you know and you're just a
regular [ __ ] like me
what do you do when you catch your
cheating
[Laughter]
what are you gonna do that'd be [ __ ]
right
and she goes yeah what are you gonna do
about it she sort of cracks her neck
you know you'd still have to take a run
at her i i swear to god
i would grab a [ __ ] the leg of a
table
you know that's what i that's that would
be what i would do i would i would grab
a blunt object and just swing below the
waist
you know because that's a lesser degree
of assault and uh
i just know that she hasn't she hasn't
any of her training
i know she can choke me out i know she
can put me in an arm bar
i know she's good standing up you know
but she hasn't dealt with weapons
i said i just started throwing [ __ ] at
her
start with a chair maybe a clock
clock's a great thing to have i guess if
that's what that would be my failsafe
if i married one of those ufc fighting
chicks i would have a bunch of
knickknacks that i would slowly be
accumulating acting as though it was a
hobby
but what it really would be is i would
be stalking it with weaponry
you know what if she's an angry drunk
comes home and just starts beating my
ass right and i gotta [ __ ] go to work
the next day
telling lies you know my name is luca
i married a ufc chick
that'd be [ __ ] brutal oh my god be
the end of your life
you know what said there has to be a guy
out there
who's just getting beat down by his
woman every night there's just no you
can't [ __ ] bring it up to anybody
you know where's that [ __ ]
support group um all right revenge
jesus christ i'm blowing through all
these questions revenge
uh bill burr i often have fantasies
about getting people back
but like you i look at my higher self
and can't do it
no that's not what i do i know i'm too
[ __ ] stupid
and i'm gonna get caught you know and
i've also watched enough sport
sports where i know that it's the guy
who retaliates
you know he's the guy always gets the
penalty
so anyways i got my revenge by living
well
and doing nothing um here's what
happened
to at least a few of my enemies and he
said i did nothing
to make this happen okay so this guy's
basically claiming
that he always wanted to get revenge but
he took the higher road and his
revenge was living well and doing
nothing so here's all these people that
he wanted to [ __ ] over but never did
this is what happened to the these
people all right first person
the dude who [ __ ] with me eventually
went to jail
for buggery and hanged himself when he
was there
what is buggery is that [ __ ] around
todd is that tom foolery what country is
this from
okay that's good now did you feel good
when he hung himself
uh another guy i hate was arrested for
selling booze to kids
and i laughed my ass off when i saw him
on a news story
about a local atf stink oh that's a good
one
another dude who [ __ ] my lady and had
the back of his
head the back of his head caved in by an
unknown assailant
not me i swear because he
buggered a child
all right dude if if any more people
suffer sort of
the same violent ending i'm gonna i'm
gonna
i'm gonna start to think that i'm gonna
start asking where you were when all
this [ __ ] happened
so anyways this guy got the back of his
head caved in for [ __ ] with the kid
he's alive but is now [ __ ]
uh you mean brain damaged uh
you know i wish women would consider the
possibility
that they're hooking up with buggers
when they go out on a girl that
their girl power [ __ ] sprees dude for
the love of god
what is buggers me i gotta look this up
i can't read the rest of this [ __ ]
what what what word am i looking up
i look up buggery
the british term buggery oh look at that
gotta love the internet
is a very close in the meaning
to the term sodomy
jesus christ and as often you there's a
bunch of people in england laughing
their ass off with me trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] that was
and is often used interchangeably in law
and popular speech
it may also be a specific common law
offense encompassing both
sodomy and bestiality
in english law buggery was first used i
don't give a [ __ ] about that i don't
care when it was first in 1533.
jesus somebody probably [ __ ] a yak
the hell do you [ __ ] 1533
saber-toothed tiger you couldn't do that
the thing would kill you
stick your dick in a willy mammoth's
trunk
all right defined punishments for the
abominable crime of buggery committed
with either
mankind or with an animal the definition
of buggery was not specific
in these or any statutes but rather
established by judicial precedent
over the years the courts have defined
buggery as including either
anal intercourse by a man with a man or
a woman
or vaginal intercourse by either a man
or a woman
with an animal
well what if you [ __ ] have anal
intercourse
with an animal is that like some sort of
uh second degree
buggery i don't [ __ ] know
but not any form of unnatural
intercourse that is [ __ ] unreal
most common law jurisdictions have now
been modified
the law to permit permit anal sex
between consenting adults
jesus they have a picture here of a guy
a depiction of buggery of a goat
by the late great paul avril
now i gotta this is wikipedia now i
gotta look up paul april
is this what he was known for
drawing painting oil paintings of
buggery
evidently he was a french painter and a
commercial artist
all right here's his gallery
he's got a couple of women maybe it's a
guy everybody kind of looks the same
she's got a [ __ ] leg spread
he's got a jesus christ this guy made
some filthy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
i see holy [ __ ]
this guy has a photo of a guy
banging a chick on his on her back while
some other dude
is putting it in his ass i'll tell you
right now
that's not buggery he is
he's committing it and haven't done to
him at the same time
what the you know what
this is this is uh
i got a little this is really creepy
wow this guy really wrote pornographic
[ __ ] okay now there's a normal one
guy and a girl okay there we go
who are you to say what's normal i'll go
[ __ ] yourself you know what i'm saying
mainstream
he's got another one of two chicks one
one's going down on the other
what the [ __ ] year was this isn't that
funny don't you always think that nobody
did [ __ ] like
1849 to 1928. so people are sitting
there talking about
the internet and all this porn and how
what it's going to do to you
look at this [ __ ] this guy was painting
buggery everybody see that you learned
something
i like to think you learned something on
every podcast
i have to go back here for all the
people here in america
okay a dude who [ __ ] with me
eventually went to jail for buggery
and hanged himself when he was there
yeah because they were probably all
screaming
chanting goat [ __ ] at him another guy
i hate was arrested for selling booze to
kids and i laughed my ass off when i saw
a news story about him at a local atf
stick
another dude who [ __ ] with my lady at
the back of his head caved in by an
unknown assailant
not me i swear because he buggered a
child
he [ __ ] the kid somebody caved his
head in all right i like that frontier
justice
he's alive but now he's uh brain damaged
you know i wish women would consider the
possibility that they're hooking up with
buggers when they go out on their girl
power
[ __ ] sprees now what do you mean by
buggers now does that mean that they're
going out with a guy who'd [ __ ] a yak
or [ __ ] a kid or going out with a guy
who wants to put it in their ass
uh i don't you you're losing me on this
one
uh please please read this letter on
your show in case
any hoes are listening yuck
i don't know what he's talking about my
woman who [ __ ] a child molester
has become a 250 pound warthog
since then so her girl power days are
over
i got rid of her 15 years ago thank god
i don't know who to be dude you kind of
sound just as
bad as the people you i mean you haven't
buggered anybody i hope but i mean you
just you definitely
yeah you're definitely a piece of work
here buddy um
yet another dude who used to pull the
most bizarre
mind games on me and others
coincidentally
had an extremely expensive divorce
i'm sorry i was just thinking of that
[ __ ] photo i couldn't get that out of
my head that someone would actually
consider doing that back in the day
that just seems like next level porno
like that seems like the future not the
past
you know like a bunch of pornography
people sitting around going all right
what is left to do
[Laughter]
gay porn we already did that
heterosexual already did that
hey wait a minute you know all these djs
are doing mashups
i have an idea um anyways yet another
dude
who used to who used to pull the most
bizarre
mind games on me and others
coincidentally had an extremely
expensive divorce
now he's poor and helpless former
boss who was a hot shot [ __ ] went to
jail for embezzlement
dude what have you been doing how do you
know all these people have gone to jail
this person goes to jail for
embezzlement this other kid [ __ ] a kid
somebody buggered some i don't know what
you know
why don't you hang out with better
people what part of the country do you
live in sir
um several other [ __ ] bosses have
lost their contacts
or otherwise got pushed into poverty or
injury by various means you know this is
starting to read like some [ __ ]
charles dickens story
is this [ __ ] really happening or is this
your fantasies
uh many other bad things have happened
to slapoffs
who hurt me and guess what i had to
visit briefly with the police in a few
cases
because they learned that i was a victim
of the douchebaggery
i think this is just science fiction at
this point but it's a good read
i have a good reputation so i was never
treated seriously
as a suspect many of these things took
years before they came out
but they happened nevertheless like
clockwork
i speak it very vaguely if anybody knows
what's going on in this i have no idea
all of a sudden i feel like i'm in some
sherlock holm [ __ ]
um are you like kevin spacey and you're
just making all this [ __ ] up
and you're gonna walk out of the podcast
and your club foot's gonna straighten
out
um i had all the revenge i ever needed
and never had to lift a finger best of
all my soul is intact i'm not dead and
i'm not in jail
the world has good things in store for
all of us
your monday morning podcast is great
thanks for cheering me up every week
every week all right sir that was uh
definitely one of the more bizarre ones
but you know something thank you for
writing in
i uh you taught me a new word and i saw
a new sexual position
[Laughter]
anyways where the hell are we
where the [ __ ] do you go from buggery i
should have closed on that
ah christ what the [ __ ] is this get this
out of the way
get this out of the way um all right
what do i do here i got like another
eight minutes to kill here
um women in the ufc
boss being in boston i don't know what
else to talk about i think i might be a
little short this week guys i really
apologize about the
unbelievably poor quality of recording
these past few weeks i just
i was really um i was really busy and i
didn't get a [ __ ] chance to uh
to do something that would only take me
[ __ ] 20 minutes let's be honest but
um
i was really stressing about that
patrice thing i wanted to make sure that
it it went
great and uh this week on on weekend on
stage i actually remembered a patrice
story that i told and i told you guys
eventually i'd be able to tell you a
story
um this is sort of a roundabout patrice
one
but it's got bobby kelly dude it's got
him in it too
i'll tell you this one and then i'm
going to end this podcast uh all right
so
when i moved to new york i moved there
basically
i had never lived on my own i went right
from my parents house to living in new
york city
i didn't know [ __ ] about the ladies
right so i moved down to new york
and i meet this girl who's an absolute
[ __ ] psycho all right like
nowadays i swear to god i could talk to
this girl for two seconds to realize
that she was out of her mind and i i
would not even i probably wouldn't even
say hello to her they're just people in
some way the way her
eyes were darting around the room i
would know that she was out of her
[ __ ] mind
but uh i was young i didn't know [ __ ] so
i ended up going out with her and you
know the crazy girls they're [ __ ]
they're great in bed
and when you're young you keep coming
back you keep coming back because you
never you never had it like that before
so i keep coming back
but she was she was [ __ ] nuts this
girl was she was crazy i mean i
i'd show up to her apartment she'd have
like a [ __ ]
like a wig on and just act like she was
somebody else
that was [ __ ] crazy then you know
[ __ ] my brains out like i'm i'm in my
twenties i'm gonna walk away from that
which i didn't realize i was like she
was out of her mind
um so anyway so i finally just said
listen i
did this ain't working out blah blah
blah blah and all of a sudden she turned
into glenn close
in fatal attraction and i didn't know
how to get rid of her
she would like call me i'm on time like
she knew basically when i was gonna be
home
and this is but i didn't have an answer
machine or anything like that did i yeah
i think i didn't know i had voicemail
and uh
she'd [ __ ] call and i'm laying in bed
and i know it's her it's late at night
none of my friends are gonna call or
nothing and
uh and i just let it go to voicemail
and i swear to god eight seconds later
she'd call again
and she was calling
like she did this for almost i swear to
god like 40 minutes straight
would just call my number it would go to
she'd let it ring six times it would go
to voicemail
and then she would hang up and then sit
there for five seconds and then call me
back and after like the [ __ ]
400th time she did this
i finally picked up the phone and i went
what
she's just like oh i just like
want to talk to you like you [ __ ]
been calling it for 40 minutes [ __ ]
straight
i'm trying to go to sleep right and i
[ __ ] hang up on her
so she ends up coming by my apartment
this girl was out of a [ __ ] mind she
was out of i
just thought of a [ __ ] mind so it
just put keeps
what i should have been doing is i
should just shut the phone off if you
ever if you're ever with like a psycho
chick like this
what you have to do is you just have to
freeze them out you have to act like
they don't exist because
if if you acknowledge them it just
fuels them and they just keep [ __ ]
coming back somebody finally told me
that just say pick up the phone say
hello if it's her just hang up on her
just keep doing that but i didn't know
to do that [ __ ] so
this is so long ago i forget what
happened i know it escalates to the
point
that she's now threatening me and she
told me
i'm living with bobby kelly by the way
so he's giving me advice he's also a
young guy
and he's also kind of laughing his ass
off and we're both kind of laughing
until one day she
she called me up and she threatened that
she was going to stab me
do something violent to me really just
freaked me out
so i [ __ ] hang up and i'm going to
bobby i'm like dude what am i going to
do you know i'm going down the cellar
tonight
i think i was at the comic strip and i'm
like my [ __ ] name
he's right on the sheet she's going to
know exactly when i'm coming in
what do i do he's like i don't know dude
i [ __ ]
you know wear two coats or something i
don't forget what the hell he told me to
do
so like two three hours goes by all of a
sudden the apartment door buzzes
and uh and it's her
and i'm like i'm like hello she's like
yeah it's me
and i'm like yeah go [ __ ] yourself and
she goes no she goes like
i want to give you something and i'm
like what a [ __ ] knife in the chest
and she's like no i i made you brownies
i'm like what i mean she went from in
three hours i'm going to stab you till i
made you some brownies so for some
[ __ ] dumb reason i
buzz her in and uh
i opened the door with the chain you
know standing way back behind and there
she is sitting there with her crazy eye
those
watery eyes that crazy people have big
[ __ ] dear eyes
she goes can i come in i go absolutely
not she goes to take the brownies i go i
don't want him she goes take him she
turns the [ __ ] tin sideways and she
pushes him through
so i take him and she goes i'll call you
later and i said yeah
okay just trying to get rid of her right
close the [ __ ] door
i sent him down on the table me and bob
are a couple of starving artists
they smell delicious
we're both sitting there staring at
these things going what the [ __ ] do we
do here
i want to eat them but she just
threatened to [ __ ] stab me
what do we do so we call up the late
great patrice o'neill
start telling the story he's [ __ ]
laughing his ass off and he goes don't
eat those brownies that [ __ ] probably
peed in the batter
so now the three of us are laughing our
[ __ ] asses off like what do we do
so long story short me and bobby
end up taking we take all the brownies
out except for like three of them
and uh we stick them back in the tin and
we're living on the ground floor
and we brought it out we stuck it on top
of a trash bag right on the sidewalk
and anything you had on new york city
man you just stuck it out there we lived
up on 97th street
we had like crackheads living in like
the the bowels of the building was
[ __ ] nuts
so anything you put out there was gone
in two seconds so we just stuck it there
we ran back in the apartment
and we just sat there peeking through
the curtain wait for some homeless guy
to come along and see what happened when
you eat them
sure enough some homeless guy comes
along he sees the tin sees him in there
picks them squeezes them sees their
[ __ ] still warm pops one in his mouth
nothing happened
me and bob looked at each other we said
[ __ ] it we ate it and they were
delicious
oh they were delicious that really
wasn't a
patrice was only in there he only made a
cameo in that one but uh
i'll try and tell some other ones later
on but
ah jesus bill you let us down on that
one did i
it was a nice crazy woman story
um [ __ ] podcast
if this is my kryptonite if i don't have
my recorder it goes down by
20 of the funny um anyways
that was the monday morning podcast for
this week oh jesus
uh thank you for listening um i don't
know what shows i have coming up
but i know you guys don't want to listen
to me clicking on my computer anymore i
i really apologize for the poor quality
of these the last two weeks uh i swear
to god next week is gonna be [ __ ]
crisp
all right that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves
and thank you to everybody here who came
out to my shows
at the wilbur theater it was
unbelievable turnout um every show was
great and you know all my family and
friends that came out people i went to
school with and it was it was great to
see everybody
and uh that is it i'll see the city of
boston i'll be back in the summer
up in new hampshire maybe down the cape
all right that's it see